We think quantum computers will allow us to solve some problems faster than we can with classical computers alone. But
understanding how is subtle. Today in Qiskit in the classroom, we'll try to uncover the source of the power of
quantum computing by looking at one of the very first
algorithms. Welcome to Qiskit in the classroom. In this series, we'll use Qiskit to explore some fundamental
concepts commonly covered in quantum computing related courses. Each video is accompanied by an interactive module
linked in the description below. So, be sure to check that out. If you've heard much about quantum computers, you've
probably heard that they can use quantum phenomena like superposition, entanglement, and interference to solve
problems in ways classical computers can't. But how exactly do these features help? In 1985, David Deutsch was the
first to show how this could happen. He came up with what is now called Deutsche's algorithm that could solve a
problem more efficiently than a classical algorithm could. Today, we'll take a look at Deutsche's algorithm and
a later extension called the Deutsch Jose algorithm and examine how the uniquely quantum aspects of the cubits
can be used to the quantum computers benefit. Then we'll run these algorithms on a real quantum computer with Kiskit.
There are other quantum algorithms out there that also show a theoretical advantage over known classical algorithms. And not all of them work
with the same principles as those we'll see today. So what we'll learn today doesn't explain in general how a quantum
computer works, but it does help us begin to see how the principles of quantum mechanics can be combined to
make a powerful quantum computer. Before diving into Deutsche's algorithm, let's first think about how quantum computers
are different from classical computers and how that might give us an advantage in solving certain
problems. One difference is that the quantum bits called cubits can be in superposition states. Instead of being
limited to either the zero state or the one state as a classical bit is a cubit
can be in a superposition state of both zero and one. We write this state like
this where a and b are complex numbers whose squares add up to one and the more
cubits the more this gap extends. Two bits can still be in only one of these
four possible states. 0 0 1 1 0 or 1
1. Two cubits can be in a superp position of all four of those classically allowed states which is
written like this. In general, a classical system of n bits can only ever be in just one of 2 to the n possible
combinations of zeros and ones. A quantum system of n cubits can be in a superposition of all 2 to the n of these
states. The scaling is exponential. So even if we had just 10 cubits, they
could be in a superposition state of 2 to the 10, which is 1,024 possible combinations of zeros and
ones. The exponential scaling of the state space of cubits is called quantum
parallelism and is partially responsible for the advantage of quantum computers over classical computers. But a quantum
computer is not just a massive parallel processor. Just because the cubits in a quantum computer can be in a
superposition of exponentially many states doesn't mean we have access to all the information in each of these
states. Since measurement collapses the system into one state or another, let's
see how this plays out in a simple problem. Say there's some machine that
you can feed a single bit to. Then it will apply some function to the bit and spit out another single bit. The machine
is inside a black box that we can't access. All we have access to is the bit
we feed it x and the bit that the box spits out f
ofx. We want to figure out what is the function f that the machine is applying.
There are four possible functions that take a single bit to another single bit.
So to find out what the function is, we can just feed it a zero and see if it spits out a zero or a one. then feed it
a one and do the same thing. Each of these two steps is called a query. This
is one way to compare classical and quantum algorithms through the so-called query model where we compare the number
of queries each of the algorithms need to make of the black box in order to solve the problem. So in this case, our
classical method needed to query the box twice to learn the function. Let's see if we can do better if we have a quantum
computer query the black box. Instead of first feeding a zero and then a one, the
quantum computer can feed the box a cubit that's in a superp position of zero and
one. So in effect, we're feeding the box both inputs with a single query. Then
does that mean that we can learn the function with only one query?
Unfortunately, that's not the case. We see why this idea fails when we test it on a quantum computer. We'll make a
circuit with two cubits. Cubit zero represented here by this top line will be our input state X that we feed to the
black box which was shown here by the maroon gate labeled UF. The UF gate is
designed to take a cubit zero as the input state X then apply a transformation on cubit one that takes
the state zero to the state f ofx. So as long as cubit 1 started in the state
zero then the output is x on cubit 0 and f ofx on cubit 1. So to find f ofx for
both x=0 and x= 1 simultaneously we can try putting cubit 0 in a superposition of 0 and 1 before
we feed it to the black box. That's done with this red hatom gate which transforms the zero state to 1 / 2
0 + 1. So after the blackbox gate, we should now have a superposition of both
f of0 and f of 1 on cubit 1. When we measure the two cubits, we're hoping to
answer the question, what function is inside the black box. Let's use the kiskuit primitive sampler to run the
circuit and return the result. We can choose the number of times the circuit is run called samples by changing this
parameter called shots here.
This is equivalent to the number of queries we make of the black box. Let's see if just one query will
work. Here's the result. We measured cubit 0 to be zero. So that was the
input value x and cubit 1 to be 1, which was the output value f ofx. So now we
know f of0 equals 1. But what about f of 1? Here's where the problem lies. Once
we measured the state, the superp positions collapsed and we only got to measure one part of the function with a
single query. This doesn't tell us everything we need to know to determine which function it is. We would need a
second query of the box for that. So even though the principle of quantum parallelism allows us to simultaneously
have the black box evaluate f of 0 and f of 1, we don't have access to both of
those answers. Quantum parallelism alone is not enough. Deutsche's algorithm
shows how we can use quantum parallelism a little differently to learn about the function inside the black box. We won't
be able to learn exactly what the function is, but we will be able to learn something new about it with a
single query that we couldn't with a classical computer. Let's start by looking at a chart of the four possible
functions taking a single bit to another single bit. Here you can see that two of the functions f_sub_1 and f_sub_4 always
return a single value regardless of the input state. We call these two functions
constant. f_sub_2 and f_sub_3 will return either zero or one depending on
the state of x. We call these two functions balanced. Deutsche's algorithm
determines if the function is constant or balanced by making some clever adjustments to the circuit we used
before. Here's the circuit. It starts by preparing cubit 0 in the state 1 /
2 0 + 1 with a hatamard as before and cubit 1 in the state 1 / 2 0 -1
with a not gate followed by a hatamard.
So the full state at this point here is where this is the state of cubit 0 and
this is the state of cubit 1. Preparing cubit one in such a way rather than just
leaving it in the state zero enables the algorithm to use quantum parallelism in combination with interference to learn
about the blackbox function. Let's see how when the cubits are fed into UF the blackbox gate a couple things can
happen. If the function is constant, then the black box will perform some operation on cubit one alone regardless
of the state of zero. In this case, since UF doesn't touch cubit zero or
care about its state at all, then the second hatomard here just undoes what
the first hatamard did. And we'll measure the cubit to be in the state zero. Let's look at the balanced function f_sub_2 as an example to see
what uf does to the state in this case. When x is zero, f ofx is zero and when x
is 1, f ofx is 1. Remember what I told you about the ufgate. It takes cubit 0
as our input x state and outputs f ofx on cubit 1. Assuming that cubit 1
started in the zero state. So for this function what UF does to cubit 1 depends
on cubit 0. If 0 is zero then cubit 1 will be left in the zero state to get f
ofx= 0. If cubit 0 is 1 the black box will apply a not gate to cubit 1 and put
it in the state one. So we get f of 1 equals 1. This is exactly what a controlled knot or a c knot gate does. A
C knot gate takes two cubits, a control cubit and a target cubit, and flips the
state of the target cubit if the control cubit is in the state one. But it does nothing to the target if the control
cubit is in the state zero. So UF for F2 is just a C knot on Q0 and Q1. The C
knot gate will do nothing to the first term since the control cubit is in the state zero. But on the second term, this
zero flips to one and this one flips to zero. And if we factor out a minus sign, we'll see that the state of cubit 1 is
unchanged. But this term has picked up a minus sign. So the state of cubit 0 is
actually the one that has changed. It went from being 0 + 1 to being 0 minus
one. When we apply the final hatomard to cubit 0, this transforms it to the state 1. So if the function in the black box
is f_sub_2, we'll measure a one instead of a zero. It turns out that the UF gate for the other balance function f3 is the
same C knot gate followed by a knot on cubit 1. That final not gate doesn't affect cubit zero. So when the function
is balanced, we'll measure cubit 0 to be in the one state at the end of the circuit. Now if you didn't follow all of
this, that's all right. I suggest you go through it on your own to see how it works. The major point here is what
happened when we applied the C knot for the two balanced functions. Cubit 0 was only used as a control cubit to change
the state of cubit 1. Intuitively, you might think that cubit 0 would remain unchanged. And yet, somehow our
operations on cubit one actually change the state of cubit zero by changing the relative phase between the two parts of
its superp position. This phenomenon is known as the phase kickback mechanism and it's
super counterintuitive like a lot of quantum phenomena. In a way, you can think of the phase kickback mechanism
like rowing a boat. The act of pushing water backwards actually propels you forward. Just like the operations on
cubit 1 actually change cubit zero. Now we can run Deutsche's algorithm on
Qiskit. Here we can select which function to put inside the black box which we've chosen to be F3. Here's the
circuit diagram of the algorithm and we can run it as before with the sampler primitive. We'll set the number of
samples to just one and see what we measure. In this case, we measured one.
So, we know that the function was balanced, which is indeed what we expected since the black box contained the function f3. So, with just a single
query, we were able to differentiate between these two classes of functions.
This would have taken a classical algorithm two queries to determine. This shows a modest advantage of quantum
computing over classical computing alone, but it's not too impressive. Just one versus two. But Deutsche's algorithm
is still extremely important to the history of quantum computing because it provided the spark that got others
thinking about larger, more sophisticated quantum algorithms.
This includes a multicubit extension of Deutsch's algorithm that demonstrates a much more impressive quantum advantage.
This is called the Deutsch Josa algorithm. It solves a similar problem, but in this case, the blackbox function
that we want to learn about takes n bits as an input and outputs a single bit. As
before, we're promised that the function is either constant, meaning the output bit is always one or always zero,
regardless of the input bit string, or balanced, meaning the output is zero for
half of the input bit strings and one for the other half. There are, of course, other
functions that take n bits to a single bit that are neither constant nor balanced. But in this problem, we're
promised that none of those functions are inside the black box. The one in the box is guaranteed to be either constant
or balanced. The Deutsch Joseph circuit looks similar to Deutsche's algorithm, but with more cubits. Here we have an
implementation of the Deutsch Jose algorithm to learn about a threebit function. This time we have three cubits
for the input state rather than just the one. And then we have this last cubit for the output state. As before, again
we prepare all the input cubits to be in the state 0 + one and the output cubit
to be in the state 0 minus one. Then although the math is a little more complicated to follow, the principle
remains the same. If the function is constant, it will not depend on the top three cubits at all. So their states
will transform back to zero after the second hatomards and our measurement will yield a threebit string of all
zeros. But if the function is balanced then when we measure the cubits following the hatoms the phase kickback
mechanism will cause one or more of those bits to be one. That might not be so easy to see this time but if you work
through each step yourself you'll soon see this must be the case. One way to check this is to try to calculate the
probability of measuring all zeros with a balanced function. You should get a probability of zero. Let's run the
Deutsch Josa algorithm on a quantum computer with Qiskit. The toughest step is probably creating the Deutsch Joseph
function. That will be our black box that we query here. This code produces a random Deutsch Joseph function that is
guaranteed to be either balanced or constant. Then we make our Deutsch Joseph circuit inserting our black box
function here. Again, we run the circuit with sampler and after we measure, we look at
the measured bits to determine whether the function was balanced or constant.
If they're all zero, it's constant. But if there's at least one one bit in the string, then it's balanced. In this
case, we get a bit string of 1 one one.
So, we know that the function was balanced. I hope I've given you your first glimpse at how quantum algorithms
can take advantage of interesting and often subtle quantum phenomena to obtain their advantage over classical
algorithms. You've probably also picked up on how tricky it can be to design quantum algorithms. Even the very first
one required a lot of creativity to achieve just a modest win over classical methods. And since that first algorithm,
physicists and computer scientists have continued to come up with incredibly inventive ways to use quantum mechanics
to their advantage, including further extensions and applications of the Deutsch Josa algorithm. If you want to
learn about some of these, as well as try out the Deutsch and Deutsch Josa algorithms for yourself, head over to
the module linked in the description to get started. Thanks for watching and I'll see you next time.